greatness for me is being able to do
something at a consistently higher level
over a long time while your field
continues to evolve and constantly
improving yourself and being the best
I've never really been
motivated for specific goals in my chess
career I just always wanted to learn and
to be better each time that I play and
now I I do have a goal of being the
first player to reach that 2900 rating
threshold in chess but what's more
important to me is the journey that will
possibly get me there it's being able to
do all the right things to give myself a
chance to do that that's a lot more
important to me in my day-to-day life